So world leaders have been caught on a candid
video recording mocking Donald Trump. And
while Republicans
are absolutely outraged at the fact that there
was a recording, there is nothing at all surprising
about this. And I'm going to explain why to
you today besides the obvious reasons, uh,
as, as you know, if you've been paying attention
to politics and you're not blinded by partisanship
or ignorance, Donald Trump has made the United
States the laughing stock of the world that
has caused the U S to not be taken seriously
on a whole host of issues at the top of the
list. Of course, climate change, but also
trade foreign policy within geopolitical alliances.
And in the context of treaties being close
to the top of the list, uh, in sort of a shared
way, Trump is not invited to lots of important
conversations on these issues. Trump has often
been condescended to at meetings of world
leaders and there have been pictures of Trump
being talked to like he's a little kid in
a room full of world leaders.
Now this is all public. Any sensible person
would guess that in private world leaders
are absolutely sick of Trump. Well, Trump
is now at the NATO summit in the U K I'll
have more coverage of that later in the show
and world leaders were caught on a candid
video as sort of hot mic moment, if you will
clearly ridiculing Donald Trump and his behavior.
This video, which we're going to play as Canadian
prime minister Justin Trudeau, French president
Emmanuel McCrone and Trump like British prime
minister Boris Johnson, when even Boris Johnson
is part of a crowd making fun of you. You
know that you are an international laughingstock.
Here's the video. You'll hear them talking
about Trump being laid about his ridiculous
press conferences about how Trump staffers
jaws hit the floor because of Trump's behavior.
Now, I do apologize to people if you're merely
listening. It is a little bit tough to hear
it all clearly for our video audience, it
is subtitled. Let's take a look
again when even Boris Johnson is laughing
at you, you are the laughing stock and this
is a real change for the American presidency,
for the office of the presidency. I'm talking
about here and I hate to see this. I really
do. I, you know, there are people who say,
Oh, the left wants the economy to crash just
despite Trump or they want, uh, the U S to
be a laughing stock just despite Trump. I
hate this. This is horrible to see. Barack
Obama disagree with his policies on many issues.
He was respected internationally. He was an
adult in the room. He was leading conversations
of world leaders as opposed to either being
condescended to or ignored or left out altogether.
I just wished the Trumpists were honest with
us. Admit Trump is a laughing stock and that
the U S is not respected. But tell us, you
don't care to pretend that everybody around
the world respects Trump fears Trump.
It's absurd. Just tell us you don't care that
he's a laughing us rat, a laughingstock rather
than denying the reality. Trump campaigned
on, everyone is laughing at Obama and if I'm
president, we're going to be respected again.
As usual, the opposite of Trump's campaign
framing ended up being the reality. And in
any case, this is just one piece of it. There
are lots of very relevant things already to
discuss from the NATO summit, which we're
going to get to momentarily. But once again,
we are not in a position of strength when
world leaders are talking together and laughing
at the president of the United States. It
could not be more of a difference from when
Barack Obama was president. And again, it's
really important to distinguish. That doesn't
mean I agreed with Barack Obama on every policy.
Quite the opposite. This doesn't mean that
Barack Obama was pushing the right policy
in all of those geopolitical summits and meetings.
Sometimes he was, sometimes he wasn't. But
we weren't a laughingstock. We now are. It's
embarrassing. It's pathetic. And it is not
going to change, not just until Trump is removed
from office, but for a while, uh, since Donald
Trump has been removed from office.